good morning John we're currently being
visited by a friend and his six-year-old
daughter and I asked her what she would
like me to make my video about today and
she said tarantulas in the guacamole I'm
gonna assume that she means let's talk
about big stupid irrational fears it's
probably not what she meant but it feels
like it might be a bit of a stretch to
spend the entire video talking about
wakka moly tarantulas so instead I want
to talk about what I think is the most
common irrational fear in America today
and that is the fear that 50% of
Americans who surround us a thoughtless
and terrible and foolish now this fear
is every bit as irrational as thinking
there might be tarantulas in the
guacamole but we all seem to believe in
I think that this comes from our
addiction our absolute addiction to
outrage I want to be clear I'm not
talking about anger at systems of
oppression or frustration at
disenfranchisement or fear that we are
making intractable decisions that are
going to have dramatic and negative
consequences for future generations
those are all completely rational
reasons to be upset I'm talking about
the continuous and unrelenting cycles of
manufactured outrage really manufactured
fear and I you know used to be a part of
and I used to encourage I used to think
that outrage was our most powerful tool
for positive change you had to get
people angry and you had to get them up
and moving and doing stuff but what I've
seen in my 35 years is that angry people
the stuff they do mostly they talk to
each other about how angry they are and
they talk to each other about how wrong
other people are and then every once in
a while they interact with those wrong
people and then they just are me and
everyone does this fake statistics get
created and passed around we burned down
straw men and we get to feel good about
it because we believe we've convinced
ourselves that this hatred and let's be
honest it's hatred is somehow like
leading to positive change
but when manufactured outrage is the
fuel with which we fight we enter into a
kind of outrage arms race where the
winner of the election is the one that
can terrify its base the most as I've
tried to put my own addiction to outrage
in check I've become a lot more
sensitive to the people who are out
there peddling in it and those people on
both sides have started to make me feel
like super sick to my stomach all right
so as we enter
far too early into the 2016 presidential
season I have already started to figure
out ways to build up my armor against
the outrage cycle it doesn't just call
me down and like make it possible for me
to get up in the morning without being
like weighed down by all of the
tremendous fear it also and I truly
believe this gives me a more accurate
understanding of the world and our
country and our culture because outrage
blinds us it is built on and builds bias
and stereotypes it makes people really
bad at understanding how society and
other people actually function so my
tools the ones I'm building my armor
against the outrage cycle our awareness
of my own cognitive biases a belief in
the fundamental goodness of other people
that they want good things for
themselves and for their families and
compassion those are the things I'm
using if you have strategies for dealing
with this please let's talk about that
in the comments in the meantime I just
analyzed the whole nerdfighteria census
of 2015 over at Hanks Channel and the
results were fascinating nerdfighteria
has gotten older by three years in the
last year which is weird have gone from
24% college graduates to 33% college
graduates evil love crash course which
is exciting the vast majority of
respondents have suggested crash course
to their friends or people in their
family and people really wanted to do
some kind of news show which after
having talked about the current state of
of news media for the last few minutes
I'm feeling compelled to do all so but
it's very hard and I don't know that
we'll be able to do it but we're looking
into it we'll try to do that thing so
thanks I'm glad that you'd be interested
in that John I'll see you on Tuesday